you should not have to compete in the
woke Olympics just to qualify for
employment or to get into a college
Merit must Trump identity politics
thank you for being here today today
we'll talk about how the history of the
paper clip has completely gone woke at
this point in time you know paper clips
are these small metal devices they used
to hold sheets of paper together but now
they represent woke ideology and some
people even bend them into LGBT shapes I
saw a paper clip painted in the pride
flag colors and we're not going to do
that in Florida and if I'm president
we're not doing that anywhere okay
they're gonna paper you realize teachers
who want to talk about gender affirming
care are using colored paper clips we're
not going to allow it in Florida and
we're going to make the entire country
floor it's it's meaningless stuff